There's so many awesome careers out there
that primarily focus on genetics every day. But
there's a growing number of careers that use
genetic information more and more all the time.
>> Now this class is just a taste of all
the genetic stories that are out there. So if you ever
hear another story, or you want a quick review of genetic
information for another genomics class, then come back and see us.
>> Now, we want to direct your attention to two important
appendices to the course. The first appendix actually has a full-length
interview for everyone who was interviewed in the
course. The second appendix actually will show you
how to extract DNA in the comfort of
your own kitchen, using nothing more than household items.
>> Now it's time for us to wrap things up,
and we really want to thank you for participating, because without
you, we wouldn't be here. And we also want to thank
our production team here at Udacity. Particularly, Taylor and Grant.
[LAUGH].
And we'd also like to thank our collaborators at 23 and ME.
>> Especially Esther Kim Jeff Pollard, Joanna Mountain, and Uta Franka.
>> And thank you to everyone who allowed
us to interview them about their life stories.
>> Now, we love getting feedback from you.
Good or bad. So stay in touch. Go to
the forums. E-mail us. And let us know if
this class has helped you out in some way.
>> Now in the mean time, go
impress your friends with your newfound genetic knkowledge.
>> And congratulations
on completing Tales from the Genome. Woo. All done. Ow. It's a wrap.